well well there's two things we're gonna
talk about today one I wanted to talk a
little bit about the exhibit across the
street the Queen within and how I feel
like fashion and chests are somewhat
related and talked also about one of my
favorite topics chest problems even
though I'm not a huge expert on chest
problems and studies they've always been
of supreme fascination to me and I also
wanted to introduce somebody who was an
ancestor of the great American player
Pillsbury who unfortunately died very
young but had an amazing chess career he
was the champion of the Hastings
tournament and he was just really far
ahead of his time and the way that he
played is everybody here heard of
Pillsbury before
yeah those of you who played chess in
him study the history a little bit know
that he was a really an American genius
I didn't know that much about him but I
obviously have heard like the pillsbury
variation which is a variation in the
Queens gambit and I remember seeing a
couple of his games and then I read a
little bit more about him and I saw some
some games so I want to show you just
one fragment it's one of the nice things
about studying classic games is that
players made more mistakes so you got to
see the illustration of some of the
plans and tactics a little bit more
frequently and it's also just such like
great fun to look at a game from so long
ago and know that we're playing by
exactly the same rules right it's been
kind of thrilling about it I wanted to
show you just a fragment of one of his
cooler games here I just go for quickly
the whole game so obviously opening
theory has changed quite a lot so I'm
gonna whiz pass through this although we
do see this this kind of opening quite a
lot today just a semi-soft and I wanted
to show you a little bit about the
tactics here now already we have this
move eight sects which a lot of times
when you have a LightSquared bishop on
this diagonal when you play h6
it seems like you're defending
because now the pond is not gonna be
able to be captured but some serious
problems can also result by playing this
move so it looks like it's a nice
defensive move stopping Bishop g5
stopping the knight from coming there
but what are some of the potential
problems with playing the move geez H
sex in these types of positions where
your opponent has a strong LightSquared
bishop strong LightSquared bishop on
this diagonal this is actually pretty
important and it comes up in a ton of
openings I mean this of course derived
from a Slav but it comes up in
terrorcons Frenchy is all sorts of
openings what are some of the negatives
of playing the move eight checks in
these types of positions obviously when
I teach beginners I talk to them about
how the move h6 makes Luft which means
that if the files open up later on into
the back rank it won't be a checkmate
because the king will be able to come
out but that's a far away because the
positions still rather closed well yeah
so kg6 is weak that's an excellent point
that Ken made so basically one of the
things is if you get a battery with the
Queen on d3 and we start hinting at
checkmating ideas on h7 well it's gonna
be harder to blunt them with g6 not that
g6 wouldn't be weakening anyway but here
it would just be almost impossible
because the bishop would just capture
that pawn on h6 right so that's one of
the major things and there's one other
thing which I guess we'll find out soon
enough anyway so Pillsbury continued to
develop
and he did put his Queen on this square
on d3 you see how that's putting a lot
of pressure on black because if black
were to move this Knight the Queen would
be able to go where yeah the Queen would
be able to go to h7 and even though
that's not necessarily meeting it's
usually not gonna be very pleasant right
I mean like it's not mating because for
instance even if the knight were to do
this so God knows why would the Queen
would come here the King would have come
to ask-- eight and now even Queen h8 is
not checkmate but it's still bad right
after Kenny seven Queen takes g7 and
we're just starting to pick off all the
pawns
so instead the much more understandable
Queen c7 and then we see a moose c5
which Pillsbury's cherdon certainly
played for tactical reasons nowadays we
were going to move like c5 and from a
positional point of view it looks very
suspect but a lot of times in chess the
strategy and the tactics are in conflict
with each other
we play a move that's positionally or
strategically suspect but it has a lot
of points to it like we want to just
like boom boom boom and get the
initiative so it's okay but why do you
think I say that that moves c5 is
positional II suspect somebody besides
Julian I think you outright rate the
rest of the class by like 500 points huh
you need to give the other people a
chance
uh-huh mmhmm exactly and and what is the
real problem with the backward upon more
than anything it gives black a nice
square for what what's what square does
that allow black the kind of yes that
night maybe come to d5 later of course
not in the near future because Queen
eight seven is still on the menu but
that's why strategically not even
looking at any of the pieces just
looking at the pawn structure that's it
and that's often what strategy is based
upon the pawn skeleton or the pawn
structure the move c5 is not desirable
but now a post Barre just gets this like
nice attacking formation with the knight
on e5 and we still have this this
formation one idea that white might have
here anybody anybody think of an idea
that white might have here if it was his
move a lot of ideas but what do you guys
think Isabel
excellent very very great okay so Isabel
suggested distracting the knight on f6
we also call that removal of the
defender or decoy it has a lot of names
the reason it has a lot of names is
because it's a pretty common tactic
getting rid of a defender so that we can
deliver checkmate or take another v's
and how would you do that Isabel did you
give me a move in algebraic notation
well you you got it though you must know
because you said you want to distract
this Knight with this Knight yes you did
yes you know how can you move this
Knight to a square that distracts this
Knight he's got to put all the pieces
together if he says it the puzzle
excellent
Knight - don't listen to Julian he's a
fish I beat him yesterday in one minute
chat and I was I was bragging in the
class that I developed some one minute
chest theory I'm not really that good at
one minute you know Grandmaster been
flying old or he Cara Nakamura legendary
at the Forum I'm like rather slow but I
get faster the more I play it and one
thing I realized playing the talented
player here Julian is that we we need to
play when we play that one minute chess
we need to play like the advanced
variation against the Karel Khan and the
French that's it use you that trick at
home you want to leave I like the closed
positions because you just move your
pieces really quickly as Wyatt you have
a little bit of initiative and then your
opponent's just under too much pressure
so anyway Nike for a great idea and I
think that pose very had that in mind as
well so Bishop takes c5 was played not
94 not as strong because the King on FA
there's a case where for the king
so pillsbury had another idea here
there's actually a couple of good moves
here which just goes to show how a great
position is but I really like his move
and this shows one of the other dangers
of making a weakening in your castle the
king position so early in the game so
what to do here is white everybody think
about it for a minute
so of course the idea Bishop c5 is that
after a pawn takes e5 Queen takes e5
getting rid of one of black White's most
powerful pieces right see that and now
it's like I don't know this is still
probably pretty good for right I feel
like everything is good for right here
but this is not as good I mean I would
consider something like because black is
up upon I mean I still think that maybe
something like this is a bit dangerous
but with the idea that if you capture
this on f6 and eight-seven will still be
up for grabs so even this could be
dangerous
although maybe black can just hang on
was a move like Queen I 5 even though
that looks really dangerous I don't see
an immediate refutation to it Queen c3
and then just Queen g5 and yeah I mean I
still feel like I'm hanging on compared
to other variations are you gonna trap
my queen I don't think you're quite
trapping my queen but maybe you're
taking on f6 and that's going to be you
mean like after this h3 and you're
taking on f6 but even here you're not
quite taking on SX and you are but I can
think with the Queen and that's not what
you wanted you definitely wanted more
than that so that was blacks idea that
maybe somehow you would get some play by
playing Bishop takes e5
so thoughts here for Wyatt md4 I don't
know it's not my favorite move this is
one of these positions where you already
have so many pieces attacking that a lot
of times you don't need upon to attack
like you might help but you might have
an easier way like usually when you're
castle on the Kings side you're trying
to attack with pieces not with pawns now
there are plenty of exceptions to that
especially it like the highest level
where they always know how to break the
rules but g4 is just like not my top
move because it's a little slow when you
already have like all these guys kind of
aimed and ready to go and only one
defender I might look for something more
direct and all these loose pieces also
all that's a signal that you might be
able to do something like right now and
that's an important ability for a chess
player to develop and probably one of
the things that really separates you
from your next level your next milestone
is knowing when to think more pretty
simple right I mean in chess you have to
ration your own time and you have to
decide when is it when is a moment in
the game where you have to play play
automatically because you're ready your
instincts are good and when you have to
sit back and say like this is it I need
to look at all the captures and checks
and really analyze and that's what the
the great players are so good at and why
you often see the top players in the
world the elite players playing a lot of
quick moves they've got their opening
prep and then they might go into an
extremely deep thing it's very typical
the problem is after Knight takes d4
you're actually threatening checkmate
ourselves on h2 and also I mean this is
really an important point because
sometimes people forget this Queen eat
some and it's not mating right and we do
have this King f8 so that's what that's
the difference when the bishop was on f8
Isabel's idea this actually would have
been made now it's just a check and the
problem is now you've got to make thread
on the menu and Queen h8 doesn't do
anything because we just go to e7 so not
the best but obviously always something
that you would look at
I think that seven is actually a good
move and the idea Julian's idea is that
now this is what kind of like a
desperado sacrifice which means in this
variation where he took on c5 our
position was pretty good but we were
down upon
so desperado means what we're gonna lose
this night anyway if we take on c5 so
not why not get a little bit of wood for
it and that's not just a little bit of
wood that's a crucial defensive pond so
White's position is just gonna be
fantastic right here because not only do
we we got the two bishops the King is in
in terrible shape and we have material
equality whereas before we had a
position like this but we were down upon
so that's definitely one way I mean I
have to say I like pulls very away even
better though the move he played here
was even was even more crushing Knight
of sevens good excellent ten said that
did he sack the bishop on h6 and yes he
did and that's why I was foreshadowing
at earlier than when you play this h6
move and you see that your opponent's
prepping for an attack I mean obviously
don't be absolute about it there's
plenty of situations where h6 is the key
defensive move but it also can be a
negative defensive move so you kind of
got the way the pluses and minuses so
after Bishop h6 if black takes what is
the key point Moses pools buries main
idea here and this is where our a little
acronym that if you've ever watched any
commentary I've done with Brad masters
are one and actually you will know I
always like to say LP do which is a
really cheesy acronym for loose pieces
drop off and what it's supposed to mean
is that whenever you have a position and
you have some pieces that are loose in
the position meaning unprotected you're
alert should go up right so you should
be thinking more sharply about captors
and jacks
just queen where queen g3 check
excellent
very good if queens of g3 check then we
can't go to h7 because the bishop 10
bishops hitting that square so our only
options are f8 and h8 and then what
would Y do does anybody see just Knight
g6 exactly just 96 check and what kind
of tactic is that hmm what kind of
tactic is that Isabel a discovery attack
and for Halloween we like to call it a
boo attack happy Halloween everyone
so the idea is that the knight on g6
says boo or discovers an attack on this
Queen which is unprotected on c7 exactly
the same fate if King f8 right then we
also play Knight g6 Jack why is Knight
d7 check not as strong as well
right the Queen get to take the night so
it's it's just so sad when you see
somebody play a brilliant sacrifice and
then they just screw it up in the end
because they get overconfident so it's I
like to always find out well why not
that so in the game what did happen I
think this Oh black played Bishop takes
d4 instead so when I saw that G take six
was going to be pretty ugly and so
instead he took on d4 and after Queen
takes before unfortunately the attack is
still extremely strong Queen comes over
to the attack and you know the problem
here is that white hasn't sacrificed
anything for this attack except for what
one pawn I mean and it just like your
king is in really brutal shape so Knight
d5 was played and now what a white play
not Queen g3 because notice the knight
protects the Queen on c7 now so this
Queen g3 idea no longer wins the Queen
right after takes Queen take c7 it's
guarded by this Knight right
so instead what happened oh sorry here
here we are
excellent means 8:6 and here we see a
very common tactical pattern why can't
black take on e5 this is a pattern that
comes up all the time it's a really
important one and I talked about like
how the smother made it's kind of hard
to see if you have to figure it out on
your own but if you've already seen it
it's almost like a building block like
you know almost like a pawn in game like
you already see it and it's a shortcut
so here there's a mate that you should
all have memorized I know you got it
who else has it this is a Czech mating
pattern that we should all have
memorized okay he's got in the back no
problem well one thing to do is always
is always get your candidate moves in
order right like Queen eight seven check
just doesn't seem like it leads to
anything
so before you start going down that
rabbit hole make sure because you might
say Oh Queen eight seven check at least
his kings in a little danger maybe I'll
play working you on very important
before you go into that rabbit hall say
do I have any choices before that most
chess players make errors by not
considering enough options
not by miscalculating something five
moves down the main branch so therefore
you got to check the other check in this
position what's the other check in this
position it's about besides Queen eight
seven check what else do you got in the
menu Bishop h7 check yes you must look
at all checks especially in attacking
positions this force is king two h8 now
what well now we've got our plenty of
options of do attacks right there's one
how many of them are there
eight but only one of them is good
although to be fair we can always
reverse if for instance if we made a
wrong line we can always reverse the
decision right you know we could just
repeat once and then go and then and
then find a crack come on be careful I
don't I have to say I don't agree with
you always repeat philosophy because
sometimes you can get get confused and
you do it twice and then suddenly it's a
draw hmm I mean you do it twice suddenly
do it three times accidentally because
you did like the first move twice but
the second move three times I don't know
I mean I guess I'm doing it once is okay
but try to be like err on the side of
safety because by the time you're
thinking about wait did I do this two or
three times you've wasted the time that
you would have saved that's the issue I
have had somebody I've done it somebody
definitely did that at least I think
twice to me actually that they had a
winning position and they decided to
repeat to gain some time in the clock
and they did it like one too many times
it happened definitely happens we I
think that one of the players was
Macklemore hair actually when he was
really young obviously I mean he was
like he was still like he was still
really strong but he was like you know
if you hundred points low rate in the me
is now yes Bishop g6 at the correct one
now why Bishop g6 because then after qg8
we have been made into so this bishop
guards is key square seven right so are
made into Isabel we're where can you
check you know it I know you know
exactly see know and then after King f8
there's main one where was I trying to
go when I played Bishop d6 exactly see
and there we go this is our one of our
most common checkmates and chess queen
right against the king protected by the
bishop right we're protected by any
piece and that that's just an extremely
common checkmate pattern because I know
it just happens all the time that you
have a queen on h6 in a bishop
that diagonal lease it happens all the
time if you're an attacking player
sounds like mm-hmm
so after 95 instead wait what happened
so queen 8 wait
Queen 8 chicks happened and then six
instead so that's a better defense f6
and now those already played this other
fine move f4 trying to get more pieces
into the attack so as you can see this
is a what those of you who listen to my
commentary also know what I like to call
move like f4 after pawn takes e5 yes the
rover the idea is that this rook is
going to come in to the attack and
that's gonna add the brutal final final
bullet here now the best move for black
is probably I mean we always think about
attacking with the Queen but the other
thing is that defense defending with the
Queen is really key so probably the best
try is Queen g7 hoping that white was
somehow tree Queens of course that
probably wouldn't happen and white would
instead play Queen h5 hitting this rock
and then just continue with the plan if
the rook moves trying to get this work
into the game with a rover right and
that just looks really hard for black
they define just you know you can't move
your king can take the night but then
work g3 and you notice how the Queen
can't move because the King would be in
check alright so that would be pretty
bad so instead
riki 7 was played but now what do I play
here so he's now he saw the rover idea
so he's trying to protect with this rock
so that his Queen doesn't get snagged so
instead of pillsbury I found a way to
win even quicker there yes Knight to g6
is when he move because now if work g7
where is the meat into someone somebody
else
I know you're still working on a test
notation yeah yeah it's Queenie cheat
and then once King comes to a seven
exactly right and this night is
protected and this is kind of an unusual
me but the night is protected by the
bishop so it's just me and I mean
there's nothing really else it's kind of
a pretty mate that if the work comes to
h7 just cuz it's kind of unusual you
don't see this checkmate that often kind
of a little variation on his mother and
me and I think yeah this just this was
just resigned at this point yeah game
was resigned so just a cool little game
so how many of you actually got a chance
to go see the exhibit across the street
the Queen within its eval dude the women
did big shocker there's a there's a
great exhibit across the street called
the Queen within it's at the world chess
Hall of Fame which I'm on the board of
and people are really coming in from all
over the world actually so I was like
doing a little refresher on Pillsbury
but people have come from all over the
world to see this show and this is one
of my favorite pieces in it the idea
that they're talking about archetypes of
the Queen and the nine archetypes of the
Queen based on Carl Jung and trying to
show like the parallels between
creativity and chess and creativity and
fashion obviously this is a very
creative piece right I mean whoever
thought of this obviously had a pretty
grand imagination and it's funny views I
was talking to somebody who was very
interested in fashion and they were
telling me about this dress and
everybody's fascinated by how it was
made because nobody really knows exactly
how they like made it look so beautiful
and elegant but yet still had leg holes
in it right
I think obviously that's got to be
really hard to do so they're out they
were saying that they think that there
were there's a bones in it like I guess
that
like a seamstress term for you know some
some things inside it and make it hold
up right and I was like what was that
good or bad and she was like well that's
definitely not as good it'd be better if
it's just like stayed up by itself right
because there's something extraneous
that helps it stay up that you don't see
that makes it kind of like less artistic
or something right and that reminded me
of test problems and chess studies which
are basically compositions that are
created to show the power of the pieces
to just create something beautiful and
to help people train to be better
tactician and more creative in chess so
they're not positions that come from a
real game right but they're still useful
for becoming stronger so I thought of
that when I when I saw this and let's
take a look at position okay
this isn't just such a stunning position
I mean this really could come up in a
real game right I mean all you've got is
the two kings and two pawns this could
easily occur in a real game weight to
move them draw so this point is going
this way so it looks kind of dire for
white because it looks like the black
king can stop this Queen and that ye is
too far away to stop this pawn right so
you look at this position you take a few
seconds and you're like oh darn it white
is just lost but white has an amazing
draw
all right so Ken
so King g7 and what would you guys
expect back to do here so yeah black
plays h4 and now what's your white dough
Julian so King Essex so it still looks
bad for right somehow all right this
pawn just keeps going and now if black
were to play what do you think black
will play here because now it's starting
to get like I'm clear it seems like
there's two valid options
so yes say black were to play King b6
now what would Y do well if we play qg5
and after h3 basically you're not
catching up with us and we're just gonna
take your upon so that looks lost
okay Nokia e5 let's see what the
difference here if King e5 is played now
the cool part is if black takes on c6
what does like do just can get for now
we're in the square of the pond right so
the pawn can't Queen because we just
capture it and if black plays h3 what do
we do so you want to play king d6 sorry
sign and then oh my king d6 and now
after h2 you play what exactly and now
when you Queen we Queen at the same time
and it's a draw right and there's no way
to score anything right and if you play
King b7 what do we play as well
beautiful King d7 and now we're actually
the first one to check whoo-hoo yes go
back to Miller there's one other main
variation so instead of king v6 yeah you
want to look at a ch3 now what do you
guys think black boy can do now after
King to e7
if white if black plays h2 what happens
again we play c7 and then if King if
Queen we're cleaning at the same time
and if King b7 again we have King d7 or
candiate so the amazing thing about this
position is just like from a visual
point of view it just looks like white
is toast
but all in this this position is the
essence of double attack that's what's
beautiful about this position then
double attacks one of the most important
principles in chess because we're always
trying to attack two things at once and
it's a tactic that comes up all the time
but here this is actually a double
attack if you think about it because
we're we're trying to go over here we're
trying to go over here at the same time
it becomes more directly a double attack
later on like in this line now you can
really see how it's a double attack
because when we play cuny five we're
threatening to play here closing in on
the pond and we're training to play here
stopping them from getting our bond so
this is a great example of simplicity
and I think that that's what's
interesting in chat that there in chess
problems there's like these two divides
like I'm a noob to chess problems but I
do notice that there's it seems to me
that chess problems and studies there's
the ones that people like because
they're so simple that you wouldn't
expect something so cool to happen
that's the beauty of it and then there
are ones that are so absurdly
complicated that you can't believe that
there's something so simple in it and
that is also a principle of fashion that
it's like you either
take something that looks really minimal
and it looks amazing or you take
something that has all sorts of
divergent elements like look at these
dresses or look at this installation by
an artist who's actually in town he
this is one of the coolest rooms in the
show it's just kind of like fantastical
whimsical installation of dresses these
are both dresses right here that you can
make something that's like kind of
absurdly complicated and yet it still
works and an example of that in chess
and this was actually a position that a
woman's a many time women's champion and
as a console this is made of one even or
not good luck guys try to find the main
in one and be sure you have it be sure
you have it you saw it before okay go do
you actually remember don't say don't
call it out but you remember okay it's
white white white to move and win top
any bits of good play let's let
everybody have a chance or this one
because because it is just a mating one
so I want everybody to try to figure it
out as well d8 is not me because you
can't do it
beep-beep-beep because it would be check
right that's why it's position so hard
it's like so many random make that seem
like they work anyone else
anybody else had some idea that was your
idea to can you imagine it so hard to
find a mate in one of course the reason
is cuz there's I'm yet for somebody you
know it would be an interesting project
for Julian's and Jordan you know the
answer is how how many checks are in
this position because but basically
that's why it's so hard right there's so
many checks because in order to define
checkmater to find the best move I
always tell my students look for all the
captures and checks in this position
there's just a lot of checks many many
tags I haven't counted them myself
yeah I guess I guess those are different
moves yes
Knight to c6 you mean well yeah that's
not me because the bishop can dig yes
Bishop d6
is not made because I can just play King
f6 right I looked at that one too I
think that was on what first one I saw
as well it's like it's like so messy at
night and you also look at this one and
then they can come back here it's like
that's amusing whoa I'm surprised nobody
gets this one that's a really that's a
really typical one to ask but then
there's this oh no no sorry
sorry this one there's Bishop Bishop e7
and then there's also and then there's
also a knight take take it's not letting
me take with a knight I think I should
make some setting but if I but if you
make a knight I think I have to change
some setting that takes away Auto Queen
um I don't know how to do that but if I
make a knight then black can go to where
yeah it then black can go King yay so
that's not made either but there is a
mate
I know right it's an absurd absurdity
that such strong tires are spending so
much time to find a mate and want it
took me a while too because I definitely
as when you're studying problems you
always look at like that the pawn takes
c8 equals 90 like that's like kind of
the first thing you look at because a
lot of what problems and studies are
many times the solution has something
surprising or paradoxical in it and
that's one of the reasons why people
like it because there's that feeling of
like wow I wouldn't have expected that
just like holes in a beautiful couture
gown yes
no that one you see it yeah what you got
no but your peach 4 is wrong too let's
put the work in the met in the middle so
did you get the number of check
scheduling you're still working on it
it's a lot so working on the number of
checks are a it while somebody else gets
the answer look we've got a lot of
missed miss tries here we did we try and
I eat
did anybody suggest uh night g6 yet and
also there's the other Bishop taking it
bishops are really getting in the way
all those light squaring bishops is
opposed right how did that happen
they've all been promoted the bishop
that's right a realistic position indeed
yeah
this wait wait you want to know error
Queen this that then I can take with the
other queen which isn't pin to the king
yeah there's a lot of peas in the mark
but you're getting closer you were
getting closer
warmer yeah come on guys we're almost
done all you need to do is find him eat
in line then you solve much more
complicated things than this he's got a
look at all the tracks like I said this
this really brings into to release what
I was saying before about how a lot of
times this moves that you're missing
they're right in front of your face it's
not missing a 20 move variation it's
missing an option that you had on the
very first move yeah whoa you got it
Queen to a three and look and look at
how she got a hashtag why is she the
only one who got a hashtag she got you
and your mom got the hashtag because
that's also it's also means checkmate
before Twitter was popular the hashtag
meant checkmate exactly and the number
sign okay that's another one and yeah so
that's that's an example of a position I
mean I and you just never expect a mate
in one to be difficult and boy when we
get into mate in twos those can be
incredibly difficult I think we're going
to look at a couple of mates and twos in
our next class where we're gonna do a
little continuation of this and we're
going to talk about some more simple
beauty and very very complicated beauty
as well